with hits like squid game don't look up
bridgeton and stranger things netflix
has long been the leader in streaming
but in april the company reported a drop
in subscribers for the first time in a
decade we're getting pretty high market
penetration
and that combined with the competition
is really you know what we think is
driving uh the lower acquisition of
lower growth the decline is uncharted
territory for the company which is
facing growing competition from other
streamers
they are maturing as other competitors
are starting to grow
here are three strategies that netflix
might try to break free of their
subscriber plateau and how these methods
have worked for other streamers
that's terrific one strategy that
netflix is already working on is
reevaluating how it creates and acquires
content we have to have an atom project
in a bridgerton every month and make
sure that that's the expectation of the
service constantly netflix is a wide
library that continues to grow
in 2021 it released more than 500
original programs according to people
familiar with the company's strategy but
it's led to a mixed bag of hits and
misses for the company netflix spends uh
upwards of 20 billion dollars a year
acquiring programming making programming
they don't want to reduce that amount
but they would like to spend it a little
better consistent quality content has
proven important for gaining and
retaining subscribers disney plus and
hbo max saw subscription spikes for big
releases like hamilton and wonder woman
84 but many of those subscribers
canceled their plans within six months
you have to strike a balance of keeping
the machine going and fresh stuff coming
in without overwhelming your customer
base but yes what you don't want of
course are large periods between new
shows coming out and or hit shows
returning another avenue that netflix
has said they will explore is adding a
cheaper ad-supported option for
subscriptions netflix has been very
against advertising against the idea of
advertising the co-founder reed hastings
has always said this is a platform built
for the viewers built for our
subscribers our subscribers don't want
ads ads interrupt the content most other
streamers already offer ad supported
options it's been a staple of hulu's
plans for years ad-supported
subscriptions make up about 59 of its
base according to data from subscriber
measurement company antenna hbo max
began offering a 9.99 subscription with
ads in june of 2021 compared to its
regular 14.99 ad free version after
about six months ad supported
subscriptions made up about eight
percent of its base according to antenna
and disney plus announced that they'd
release a lower cost ad supported option
later this year a small but growing
number of subscribers are choosing
ad-supported plans according to antenna
they accounted for 32 of streaming
signups in 2021 compared with only 19
the year before which translated into a
small increase in subscriptions as well
of course what netflix doesn't want to
do is see a lot of their current
subscribers who pay a lot of money to
not have commercials decide economically
it's a better bet to deal with some
commercials so they're going to have to
balance that out but the hope is new
revenue from commercials new subscribers
coming in saving money accounts for
about 30 of subscription cancellations
in the u.s according to survey data from
kantar entertainment on demand offering
a lower price might entice more holdouts
who don't want to pay netflix's current
lowest plan people are being very cost
conscious these days the idea that you
cut the cord and save money through
streaming is a little bit of a myth and
the more these services go up in price
the more people will realize it's a bit
of a myth the trickiest strategy netflix
wants to focus on is cracking down on
password sharing an issue that streamers
have been trying to solve for years
streamers have a love-hate relationship
with password sharing streamers don't
want to be the bad cop cracking down on
people sharing their passwords but at
some point it becomes so widespread that
it affects the bottom line netflix
estimates that password sharing is
losing them a large portion of customers
222 million households subscribe
worldwide but the company estimates that
an additional 100 million households
access the service through shared
passwords viewer penetration is made up
of two groups one is a group that's
paying us which is great and then there
is a group of viewers that um are not
paying us and they're uh sharing someone
else's account credential and we really
see that second group is a tremendous
opportunity netflix already has some
measures to prevent password sharing
there's a limit on the number of
profiles an account can have and
different subscription levels have caps
for how many devices can be watching at
a time other streamers currently follow
similar models a new method netflix
might try is adding an additional charge
for accounts used in more than one
household they're already testing
subscription models like this in chile
peru and costa rica there are going to
be customers upset people get used to
getting something for free or feel like
i subscribe i should be able to share
this with my son and my daughter or live
in another state and so they're they're
going to have to be do a good job in
explaining that the only way we can keep
bringing you all the programming you
love is to have
more revenue to make it whatever netflix
chooses to do the industry will be
watching closely if netflix is going to
try to be more efficient or to use their
words right size their programming
budgets that has a ripple effect on the
rest of the industry i'm sure for the
rest of the industry they're thinking
great these guys have been overpaying
and blowing budgets out of proportion
for years so now everything may actually
return to some sort of sense of normal
in addition to these measures netflix
will also likely turn their attention to
international markets like asia where
streaming is still fairly new and not
yet saturated
you